we wanted to kind of investigate the the
political attitudes a little bit more um
uh and 39 said they were right-leaning
17 said they were centrist and 45 said
they were at roughly 45 said they were
left-leaning so um not what we expected
to find given what the media kind of
reports but if you think about it with
in-cell rhetoric being quite based
around
uh redistribution of sexual access it
kind of maybe makes sense from an
extreme left-wing point of view
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
phd researcher in the field of
evolutionary psychology william costello
welcome to trigonometry thanks for
having me on happy to be here it's
really good to have you on man uh before
we get into the conversation we really
wanted to talk to you specifically about
incels because that's something we
covered recently and you will go in
touch with us and you will hear some
data and facts and research on it so we
thought we'd be really good to get you
on to talk about it more before we do
though tell everybody a little bit about
your background how are you where you
are what's been your journey through
life that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us sure so i moved from
ireland to england for my undergraduate
degree 11 years ago
just last year i graduated from brunel
university london
with a master's in psychology culture
and evolution and my research
dissertation topic
was in cell psychology and uh my
colleague and co-author she always jokes
to me that people say that research is
me search so i've no comment on that
from my side of things and but i'm just
about to move to austin texas to join
the david bus evolutionary psychology
lab there as a phd student and
researcher and uh yeah so that's kind of
me and my journey yeah in a nutshell and
it's good to see you've lost the action
in 11 years
yeah and pick up the romy one but and
david bus of course being the founder of
basically the creator of the field of
evolutionary psychology so that's an
amazing move for you congrats uh but
let's talk about what you wanted to talk
to us about because we've we've had some
guests on we've and we touched on the
subject of in cells but you've done a
lot of very interesting research into it
so for anyone coming to this issue for
the first time doesn't know anything
about it who are in cells how do you
define them etc right so incels are a
kind of an online subculture community
of men who form a strong sense of their
identity around what they perceive as
their inability to form sexual or
romantic relationships uh they believe
in something called the black pill after
a lot of manny in cells believe in
something called the black pill which
means
in their case that there is simply
nothing they can do to improve the
romantic prospects and that it's over
for them in terms of competing on the
mating market uh a significant minority
of incels engage in what we call
misogynistic online hostility but one
study found that just 10 of incels are
responsible for the vast majority of the
extreme hateful content
online uh so like any other group it
kind of tends to be the fringe
minorities within that community that
shout the loudest and maybe get used as
emblematic of that community in rarer
instances still
incels have lashed out in violent rage
the most famous case is elliot roger
who in ilsa vista in california in 2014
he
wrote a 49-page manifesto talking about
how he wanted to have a day of
retribution where he would kill chads
who are the sexually successful men
right yeah and
uh
and so stacey's are the sexually
successful women that reject him so he's
really like kind of resentful and how
prototypical he is of uh
typical of an incel
is not that clear from a psychological
point of view which is what i wanted to
kind of study but always in the media
you'll see two cases always brought up
the elliott roger case and the alec
monasian case alec monasian is the guy
in toronto who drove his van into a
crowd of people and killed
10 in that attack and he's just actually
the other day been sentenced to 25 years
to life so
worldwide the in-cell death count
attributable to incels is about 50 to
60. alec monasian alone can account for
10 of those and he's
always reported on in the media as the
typical kind of insult um but what's not
often reported on is the judge's verdict
last year came out where the judge if
you look into the report said that the
alec monae's in he clearly piggybacked
on the incel movement to gain notoriety
and to get more kind of infamy
associated with his his act of violence
and that's kind of i have a bit of an
issue with the way the media report on
the insult problem because by giving
such a notoriety
to these attackers it could potentially
inspire future spree killers you know i
mean
what if you were seeking to gain
notoriety you can get your youtube
videos splashed all over the news and
that goes directly against uh kind of
media guidelines from anti-terrorism
kind of uh organizations and
particularly when you're dealing with
people who are low status who are
seeking status that would seem to be a
very dangerous thing to be doing
absolutely yeah so it's kind of it's a
dangerous game to play and uh but yeah
beyond that i just think it's very
unfair to
the wider kind of intel community which
would uh to kind of hold up the most
extreme actions of an extreme minority
within that community as representative
we tend to rail against that attitude
about other groups for example it's
harmful stereotype to stereotype muslims
as terrorists
based on the actions of an extreme
minority um so those figures maybe uh
might come as surprising to some people
who kind of think well the vast majority
of insults are misogynistic and
potentially violent william it sounds
like you've got a great deal of sympathy
for these people or these blokes i
should say well well yeah i mean
my sexual and romantic relationships in
my life have been some of the most
enriching and experiences available to
people so
for
for that to come for for it to happen
that incels form their identity to have
such psychological pain with the
prospect of trying to form romantic
relationships that it forms their
identity i imagine that must be a
significant kind of pain and you know i
just think it's a poorly understood
topic and uh we could do better
to understand better the problems in
cells face and represent in society and
that's why i set out to to study them
and
maybe i'm being judgmental here how much
of this is just a load of blokes just
being incredibly self-pitying and going
pull me poor me poor me because look
there's all been times in our lives
where we've struggled to get a date
we've struggled to get a girlfriend
is it really the answer to go online and
then feel sorry for yourself or am i
being incredibly unsympathetic uh right
no you're not wrong and you know we've
it it's a to be sexually successful you
have to kind of go through a lot of
rejection right and it may be the case
that incels are just very high on
rejection sensitivity and uh but it
could be that just participating in the
mating market causes them a lot more
anxiety than the typical person but i
think you might be familiar that uh
victimhood is in vogue these days yeah
so particularly online so i think
infills disenfranchised young men rather
than competing in an anxiety-inducing
mating market they said i'll have a
piece of that victimhood pie and form my
identity largely online um around this
this identity so and of course you talk
about it in this in some of your
research that there are certain criteria
for uh and a lot of studies have been
done and to show what percentage of
incels do this and that and the
psychological traits the predisposed
people so if we we talk about the
mainstream media coverage i want to just
come back to that for a second uh one of
the points you made is that in your
research for example so the basic
mainstream narrative is these are far
right white nationalists you know
chauvinistic sexist and of course there
are some who are but actually some of
the research you you you've done you
found that these are disproportionately
ethnic minority people actually for
example right
and also you i think you found that some
of the stereotypes are true like half of
in cells live with their parents so the
basement dwelling stereotype
you know is fairly accurate what are
some of the other statistics that you
can share with us about these groups
sure yeah and that was a significant
finding that we had around the kind of
we wanted to confirm or dispel this idea
that they're far-right white supremacist
movement so yeah
36 of our sample of 151 uh male in cells
were of color people of color and it was
a largely us and uk sample so that is
disproportionate and fewer in cells were
white than would we would expect by
chance um just to give you storage from
william bright color let's break it down
do they come predominantly from one type
of background is it like black caribbean
black african pakistani bangladeshi etc
so there was a as i recall a little
disproportionately more on south asian
in in our sample uh but uh for this
statistic i kind of clumped all the the
people of color together versus white
because the majority were white uh given
our sample with us and uk uh but nothing
overwhelming uh of one particular
minority just uh but but incels are
quite um
the the idea that they might be white
supremacist and uh far right always
struck me as a little bit odd because in
cells are very concerned online with
what they see as the racism of the
mating market so they think that dating
is quite racist and there is perhaps
some statistics that bear that true and
so it seems a very unusual thing for a
bunch of white supremacists to be
concerned about racism in the dating
market right so and so just i didn't
know that william can we just double
click on that quickly before we i want
to hear all the data as well
when you say they're concerned about
racism what what do you mean so they're
they're highlighting what they see as
the unfairness of the dating market in
every sort of way they can see but one
of the ways is that they say oh it's
quite racist people's dating preferences
are somewhat racist so
the idea that some races do particularly
better in dating than others okay it
seems a strange thing if you were a
white supremacist you would not have an
issue with that but they they do they're
they're concerned about i haven't heard
that yeah anyway please carry on so uh
for the levels of well-being that we
wanted to investigate so there's many
reasons to think that in cells commonly
report that they struggle with their
well-being and
have mental health issues so we used the
nhs um instruments the phq-9 to measure
depression and the gad7 to measure
anxiety and 73 percent of in cells in
our sample versus 33 of non-in cells
could be clinically diagnosed as having
severe and or moderately severe
depression
percent of in cells could have severe or
moderate anxiety based on nhs guidelines
versus 38 of non-in cells and 82
of in cells in our sample said they had
strongly uh considered suicide
we wanted to kind of investigate the
political attitudes a little bit more
and it wasn't the main finding of our
study but we did ask one question about
political attitudes um
and 39 said they were right-leaning 17
said they were centrist and 45 said they
were roughly 45 percent said they were
left leaning so
um not what we expected to find given
what the media kind of reports but if
you think about it with in-cell rhetoric
being quite based around
uh redistribution of sexual access it
kind of maybe makes sense from an
extreme left-wing point of view but you
brought up the good point about the the
kind of the stereotype of insults still
living at home and one might be tempted
to think okay 50 of in cells still
living at home but perhaps they're quite
young the typical incel is a young male
right uh however the mean a the average
age for in cells in my sample was um 27.
so
you would expect you wouldn't perhaps
expect that 27 year olds are still
living at home now it's become a lot
more difficult to get on the housing
market particularly if you don't have a
partner
you actually kind of need a dual earning
household to get a mortgage pretty much
these days so it's a double double
whammy for in cells to get circularly
punished because
being neat not engaged in education
employment or training so 17 of in cells
versus nine percent of non-incels are
considered neat and that would have a
real impact on their dating prospects
because particularly for men
socioeconomic status is a a very
important factor
what it sounds like when you're
describing these men and i'm actually
getting more and more sympathy the more
that we go through this interview they
just sound like blokes have fallen
through the cracks in society right yeah
it's just disenfranchised young men and
unfortunately historically
disenfranchised sexless unpartnered
young men a surplus of that demographic
of people in a society is has
historically been very dangerous in the
evolutionary psychology literature we
call that young male syndrome and
they're typically the most prone to
crime because they have elevated risk
taking and status striving behaviors
so i recently heard it described as
that they have like a need for chaos
that they'd rather just tip the whole
monopoly board of society over rather
than participate in it because they feel
we don't have a stake in this society
and nothing gives a young man a stake in
society more so than a partner so and
and on that point uh
first of all incredibly worrying that
china has a large number of men who
can't get married basically
but also the question i wanted to ask
you is
is it a case of we've got more people in
that position than we've ever had or is
it a case where we now have technology
that allows people who otherwise would
have been
sitting in their mother's basement and
playing computer games well now they
have a community we all now have a
community we're all part of some
community and we can go online and we
can talk to other people who are part of
that community
and we become embedded and i know one of
the concerns particularly within cells
is
the being on an in-sell forum they don't
want you to get better right the moment
you start actually getting dates and you
know whatever
you become very ostracized right so is
it a case that we've got more people in
this position or is it a case that the
tools of modern communication have
allowed people to get together and be
like we're all in cells together right
so yeah touched on some very very key
points there so historically uh
throughout our evolutionary history we
always have had a greater variability of
male reproductive success so
a lot of men throughout our evolutionary
history haven't got to reproduce so
we've always had uh
an incel problem however we had
institutions to kind of deal with this
kind of surplus population you had
monasteries you had even unfortunately
maybe an unpalatable idea is the idea of
war and sending young men off on raids
with the the promise that they will be
able to get a wife that way so mary
harrington who i understand you've had
on the show
she wrote a really interesting article
on insults as the new vikings so vikings
historically would have been
prototypical in cells unpartnered young
men who could be sent raiding in war so
those uh kind of cultural institutions
aren't really available perhaps
i think it's clear that's a good thing
but it does leave us with this surplus
population i think you're right that the
online worlds have
given all sorts of communities a chance
to kind of galvanize around together and
that might make this particular group of
incels uh unique in history to be the
first to consciously grapple with the
fact that they they may be to some
extent an evolutionary dead end uh
directly which is you know
might really mess with someone's psyche
there's also
the kind of modern features of the
modern mating market that are
evolutionarily mismatched with our
ancestral mating market that maybe
exacerbate problems there as well so if
you think about it in our ancestral
environment you would have encountered
perhaps uh a couple of dozen potential
mates in a lifetime so persistent sexual
rejection would have been perceived as
catastrophic you know if you if that got
a up and running you could potentially
oh i'm a dead end here um whereas that's
not quite the case now but the rejection
still hurts the same and someone in the
modern dating market with dating apps
big cities transport around could
encounter more rejection in one day than
would be possible in a lifetime in our
ancestral environment so for the psyche
still remains the same so that that may
compound the any negative effects on
well-being and a couple of other
evolutionary novel features of the
modern mating market are
the online way it's ubiquitous way to
meet your partner now i think 70 plus
have people since 2017 have met their
partner online and that means that the
the competition you're up against is
everybody in the wider vicinity not just
who's in your neighboring tribe it's
just the whole world is against you and
the way that works negatively is that
for an incel a woman of maybe similar
what we would say similar mate value but
she might be able to
to meet a guy of higher mate value
online and he will be willing to
to have a sexual experience with her
maybe once or twice but not commit to
long term but she gets the idea that's
my level and that's what i want now i'm
going to keep chasing that and perhaps
you'd say well why shouldn't she
you know but um it may also be an
uncomfortable truth that we have to
wrestle with that for most of our recent
history women had been settling with
guys that they really weren't that keen
on but just out of strict monogamy norms
and strict uh economic necessity they
kind of had to now that women are
beginning to outpace uh men in education
certainly and up until the age of 30
economically
they're kind of there's a mismatch of
highly educated and selective women
versus economically unattractive men
because the the female mate preference
for a similarly high earning or a
higher earning partner still remains so
those minority of men at the top so
there is a sign of some truth to this
cliche of a minority of men are kind of
monopolizing the attention
that's borne through in a lot of studies
that we see and in a lot of
kind of facts and figures that
illustrate that point there is some
truth to that and when you have a
minority in any sex ratio they call the
shots in terms of
sexual behavior so if there's
only a minority of women in a a society
the men are more
keen to commit long term whereas if you
have only a minority of eligible men
then they call the shots and they're not
they're reluctant to commit and the
the sociosexuality of the other sex has
to mirror the whichever is in the
minority it's a fascinating uh way to
look at it like something so fundamental
as sex ratios and uh there was even one
really cool study
uh that these researchers called rob
brooks and candace blake they were able
to predict geographic areas of high
online intel activity based on three
variables number one high income
inequality overall number two small
gender pay gaps so women earning nearly
as much or more than men and number
three male biased sex ratios so fewer
single women so all of those together
could predict geographic areas of
infills around the country though that
was amazing
hey francis do you want to store all
your internet passwords in one place so
they're safe and easy to remember
meaning that there's less chance of your
internet security being compromised of
course that's why i use venezuela's
number one password manager gringo
security
it's as reliable and as stable as our
currency
what's the current inflation rate in
venezuela uh three million percent you
know three million isn't good right
three million is incredible value for
money mate imagine if you went to an
exam and got three million percent you'd
smash it you realize three million
percent means that the currency is
worthless as is that rubbish software
you're using no
i've put all my money into gringo
security my savings of two billion
bolivars have been evaporated look on
the bright side francis two billion
devices about 20 quid and now you can
use a proper password manager trusted
the world over nordpass it's
consistently rated as one of the best
password managers real money can buy but
nordpass is much more than that it's the
essential cyber security tool that makes
everyone's life easier and safer it's a
simple easy to use and very secure
password manager created by the cyber
security experts that built nordvpn the
advanced online security and privacy app
trusted by more than 14 million users
worldwide it's dead easy to use because
it stores all of your passwords and it
syncs them across six devices so there's
no awkward fumbling when you're trying
to watch problematic content like
trigonometry you can shop and browse
faster securely store your credit card
and personal details on nordpast instead
of tediously tapping away on a keyboard
a few clicks and it's all done it also
has a data breach scanner so if your
online account or credit card
information has been leaked you can
identify where and when the leak
happened and what type of data was
compromised and no one knows your
passwords apart from you not even nord
to sign up simply go to nordpass.com
trigonometry and get one additional
month for free when you use the code
trigonometry go to nordpass.com
trigonometry and use the code
trigonometry for one additional month
for free
and what about the fact that if you take
if you look at love island which i
despise and i think is a symbol of our
society slowly crumbling and falling
into the sea but if you look at
what they think is
masculine beauty it's a very specific
type of guy buff to within an inch of
his life a certain height a certain set
of features now this is replicated on
instagram and all the way through our
media is it any wonder that some lads
just look at these blokes and go well
this is what it means to be a good
looking bloke i'm never going to achieve
that so what's the point in taking part
well yeah that's exactly it and they
might just say it's
so hurtful to actually try and
participate in this that how has it come
to be that a significant portion of our
young male population would prefer the
victimhood identity of inseldom than
actually participate in made in
competition you know they must be
getting something out of this identity
so they do they get fraternity they get
a common enemy a simple way to kind of
view the world and
one idea from
diana fleischman who i believe you had
on the show as well she put forward the
idea that because of pornography these
men who are staying at home
and not participating in the mating
market they're getting what is called
counterfeit fitness cues from
pornography that tells them you're being
a reproductive great success because
you're
having the sexual stimuli you're
ejaculating and those two click together
and they think there's no point in going
out yeah
yeah you're kidding us to stay at home
seeking status at home i think it was
jordan peterson who said this that what
we're feeding our young men with video
games and pornography is the worst of
both worlds because when you play video
games you feel that you're becoming
successful that you're improving that
you're hitting all these stats and
targets and i remember do i had the
experience of a lockdown where i was
playing championship manager whatever
football manager and i and i won the fa
cup and then i signed the contract for
being on 80 grand a week and i'm like
yes and then i look round at my little
flat and i went the [ __ ] am i doing
right right yeah that's a really good
analogy because i i was addicted to the
football manager as well so i know and
it's such a futile sense of seeking
status because you can't even share it
with your friends and but yeah i
wouldn't actually not with women that's
not gonna help right yeah it's not sexy
they're very they're not very
open-minded when it comes to your
success right yeah but i wouldn't be so
hasty to kind of throw the baby out with
the bathwater and say it's all negative
that the status seeking is kind of uh
kind of zeroed in on online worlds
because that might actually be what's
stopping in cells being more of a
violent disruptive process in society
because if they weren't seeking status
in these online worlds they would
potentially like uh all the other
evidence for young male syndrome be
doing it out in the world so
you know while the online hostility and
the kind of um
disenfranchisement of young men in
society
it might be a problem on one hand it's
it's all it may present a bigger problem
if you get rid of it so it's um what
about the uncharitable way of looking at
this which is
to look at these men and go right so
they join these communities because they
want fraternity and all the other
reasons you explained which all make
perfect sense to me and then going and
then me thinking well you've just picked
the easy route here mate
instead of working on yourself instead
of going out and going you know this is
what i want to do with my life and
working really hard and maybe having to
work two jobs or whatever it may be yeah
you just sat in your room feeling sorry
for yourself and your mates
who you've never met before yeah
absolutely and uh you know
the idea of getting the girl has been
motivational for men to improve
themselves and seek status a lot and
there's an interesting paper called the
evolution of the manosphere that talks
about the
pick-up artist to in-cell pipeline so
incels actually came about because they
originally tried pickup artist uh camps
or routines didn't really work and they
said oh i've tried to gamify this system
it didn't work i must be in cell and
they just hunkered down into the
victimhood of that identity then but
there's a funny thing that happens when
you acknowledge or when you explicitly
attach the goal of achieving
getting a girlfriend to any form of male
self-development do you remember a
couple of years ago barack obama when he
wrote his autobiography and he wrote a
couple of chapters on it about in
college he started reading certain books
to impress girls
and i think that resonates with a lot of
men of you know you try any trick to
kind of it's a real motivator to go and
improve yourself but barack obama was
like lambasted in the media for oh how
misogynistic you know he's doing all
these manipulative tactics to try and
get particular girls like he was saying
i read this marxist literature to
impress one girl read this other
literature to impress another one and
you know that seems pretty innocuous to
me and it seems typical of me women
would never manipulate men together
right they'd never put on makeup or
anything like that
right yeah that wouldn't happen uh but
uh look uh before we i want to talk
about
some of the pathways out because i think
it's important and i i know that
there'll be people who come across this
video on the internet who are in sales
and so i want to talk about some of the
potential pathways to success out of it
because i think
this is the thing that i think people
don't realize is
uh there's a difference between men and
women and one of the differences between
men and women is that uh women
can victim their way out of problems
sometimes
that's not going to work for men you're
not going to victim yourself out no
one's going to give you [ __ ]
for being a victim when you're a guy and
fair unfair right wrong i don't get it
that's how it is yeah right you're going
to have to work dig your way out of it
yourself so i want to talk about that
sure but before that how does one become
an incel is it something that you think
is a genetic predisposition is it part
of you you get mentally unwell you may
be a bit depressed maybe this happens
that happens like what's the pathway uh
yeah so i'd be very reluctant to kind of
pathologize in seldom as like a any sort
of genetic thing um
you know just for any amount of reason
someone could have enough difficulty in
the dating arena and enough
psychological problems that it causes
them enough psychological distress that
this becomes their identity i think
that's all there is to it it's not like
it's not a disease or anything like that
i wasn't saying that but people are
genetically predisposed to all sorts of
things good and bad right certainly yeah
i'd be very surprised if there was one
maybe some kind of genetic disposition
for low mating effort and
more reluctance to try in the amazing
arena um but i think it's more a kind of
like a subculture phenomenon right that
plays into kind of psychological uh
issues that people are experiencing uh
so one thing we found that incels in our
sample scored very high on a new
personality construct called the
tendency for interpersonal victimhood
and when i describe this tendency you
might recognize it in a lot of groups
actually and you might think oh we
should test it on this other group so
it's comprised of four different
sub-dimensions
the need for recognition which is a
preoccupation with having the legitimacy
of your grievance acknowledged so the
worst thing you can say to an incel is
you know what you're not actually that
bad you could actually pick yourself up
by your bootstraps and go out they
really hate that they're like no that's
what i'm about to [ __ ] say right yeah
and that's what jordan peterson says his
anytime he spoke about incels you know
he
what what you might expect or what some
media might expect jordan peterson to
say about them it was way off he said
i won't do a jordan peterson impression
he said basically oh incels if you say
that uh all women don't want you then
they're right they're they're not wrong
all the women in the world that don't
want you can't be wrong you need to and
like he's the ultimate guy for
self-development right if he can't save
themselves and no one can but that was
his kind of take on it
so that was that need for recognition
the second is moral elitism so they
scored high on believing that the
individual or their in-group behaves
more morally than others the third is a
lack of empathy can we pause on that
sorry william this is like absolutely
brilliant i'm so glad we had you and to
talk about this
when you talk about this second point
uh can you expand on that a little bit
so so that was the moral allegiance yeah
like in what way do in cells in cells
think they're morally superior to the
rest of us right so they might maybe
categorize female mate preferences or uh
our kind of amazing behavior as quite
superficial and shallow right like
they'll be like women like money and
tall guys even though i'm a really nice
guy on the inside right that guy's an
idiot and you can make the argument
particularly if you're a short man you
can make the argument for that being the
preference for height being quite
arbitrary and shallow and superficial
but you know it doesn't it doesn't serve
me very well to hunker down into that
argument you got to go on the
compensation game real hard that that's
the tactic um but yeah that's the kind
of moral elitism that they have right um
the lack of empathy so that's a belief
that because of their past victimization
that they feel entitled to enact pain on
others uh and they don't they say oh
well no one cares about my pain so why
should i care about yours and sell score
high on that dimension two and the final
one is rumination so they have a
tendency to constantly ruminate on past
instances of perceived victimization and
that might that rumination piece might
point to pathway to a therapeutic way
out for in cells they're quite resistant
to therapy
initially anyway but i have some ideas
on that too but
tackling the rumination through what's
called metacognitive therapy which is
thinking about your thinking and kind of
cultivating an internal locus of control
so that in cells believe they can
actually affect change right in in their
environment because that's
one thing we found from our study was
that the belief in the permanency of
inseldom was a significant predictor of
depression and anxiety among
if you think in
life's gonna be [ __ ] forever that sort
of would make you depressed i'd imagine
so cracking that black pill is actually
crucial yeah so
i yeah let's talk about the way out
because like i say i don't think
victimhood has ever
it's not gonna help particularly men
because society doesn't feel sorry for
men for reasons you you're better
qualified to to elaborate on than i am
so
the my answer would always be the jordan
peterson answer we just talked about
which is at the end of the day
you have to you have to be better right
the reason women aren't attracted to you
is their perception of your mate value
is low yeah right now you need to raise
that yeah and actually one of the ways
that men are somewhat beneficiaries of
the system is that it's much harder for
a woman to raise a mate value than it is
for a man because
for
men talk about superficial men are all
about the looks like you can't really
change that too much as a woman but as a
guy if if you think that women are
shallow and they want money well
but there's some things you can do about
that yeah you know if it's is it
charisma is it being funny is it
whatever those things are those are
actually things you can work on right
right and i would argue that is going to
be a big part of any solution to to
coming out of that situation right yeah
absolutely and i i very much agree with
you for the most part about uh male mate
value being more kind of changeable and
you can work on it except for the height
and that is a significant one because
it's a very kind of stark finding that
there's a a cut-off point for most women
uh
with in terms of height but for the most
part i certainly agree with you but it
depends on what our goal should be that
all of that is based on the assumption
that the goal should be that the in-cell
majority of in-cells should go out and
get girlfriends now that might be the
psychologically healthy thing for
maybe even most in cells but there will
be a significant minority where that
would actually be cause of more anxiety
and actually that could be really
uncomfortable for the women that they go
out and try and pull because these are
not well-adjusted people to be in right
and you mentioned oh there's charisma
and there's uh personality for sure but
there's also the halo effect that we
perceive people who are attractive to
have better personalities it's also not
that easy to just develop a very winning
personality particularly if you're
anxious already it's kind of hard to go
out and do that
a lot of incels report to being autistic
it's not something i measured in my
study but they've done their own
in-house uh studies on that to say that
they the
over-representation of autistic people
among themselves um so yeah that
cultivating a winning personality isn't
isn't that easy
um
yeah but see this is what people like
you're not allowed to say this in modern
society but things like anxiety for the
most part they're not without cause like
when i was 18 years old i remember it
was the first time i went to get a job
i'd go to the student employment office
at my university and i would be sweating
buckets because i was so anxious i
didn't know what to do i felt
uncomfortable i thought they'd judge me
for not having any not all of that right
anxiety is very often simply a symptom
of the fact that you're not prepared for
the situation that you're putting
and everything you want
everything you want in life lies at the
other end of a journey of a lot of
anxiety yeah that's just life right and
so you're not going to get anywhere if
if being anxious is stopping you from
doing stuff and the only way you get
less anxious is by doing stuff that
makes you anxious that's been my
experience yeah and you tap into
something there actually
and to get like to be sexually
successful with women you have to really
love women and really want it right and
willing to put yourself out there
through all the pain and rejection and
come out the other side right maybe it's
just
maybe there's like a an element where
it's just not that it's not worth the
pain for in cells now perhaps it's
linked to pornography meeting those
sexual needs at home at a an easier
level um but that's perhaps only going
to get worse if you think of virtual
reality pornography sex robots things
like that are going to exacerbate that
problem a little bit more so you tell me
then what what are the answers how do
the the majority of installers let's say
who maybe can function in a relationship
well right how do how how do they get to
where they want because the thing is
underneath all the depression the
anxiety and and all the hatred and all
the [ __ ] yeah these are just young
men who want to who want to have a
girlfriend right right and there's
nothing wrong with that that's a
beautiful thing to aspire to so how do
they get there if they're watching this
so uh there is the issue of
which direction is the causality are
they depressed because they can't get
girlfriends or can they not get
girlfriends because they're depressed
and anxious but i predict that it's
bidirectional and one affects the other
and kind of it's cyclical um there is a
lot you can do to improve your mating
intelligence you can and like you know
the figures i pointed to about being
neat and still living at home those are
fundamental things that i think would be
improvable a lot of the time with young
men particularly to young infels i know
they would think it's patronizing when i
advise them on this but just even
waiting until you're 30 rather than 20
is such a game changer for men in terms
of uh
because women typically don't really
like to to go out with men that are much
younger than them so when you're 20 the
pool of women that are potentially even
interested in you is really small it's
like really close to your age but as you
get old up to around 30 the women who
are approaching 40 are interested in you
and the women who are closer to 20 are
potentially interested in you too so
just a sheer age thing is important and
you accrue more status as you get older
you achieve more in life and have more
to show get a bit more experience
socially and so yeah i think there is a
lot just fundamentally on their
socioeconomic status um
that we could do but the in cells would
probably say
yes okay i hear you i need to improve
but they're what they're really railing
against is the
the sudden unfairness of it compared to
let's say the 1950s where pretty much
every man was guaranteed uh
to get a job and to get a wife they see
that that's suddenly culturally been
taken away from them really suddenly and
we haven't started rewarding different
things so we've done a great job of
bringing women into the workplace who
haven't done a great job of bringing men
into the home or that even being
considered sexy you know
maybe we could do both things maybe we
could try and improve the socio-economic
status of young men on one hand and
maybe we could also start rewarding
things like stay at home further and
things like that but one study pointed
to women's mate preferences that just
five percent said that they desired a
relationship where they work full-time
and men work part-time or not at all
that's just five people this is what i
was going to say man as an evolutionist
psychologist do you think that's ever
going to happen though because i'm not
sure we're wired that way are we it's
not uh it doesn't seem to be it hasn't
been the tendency cross-culturally at
most places but it's a very unique
evolutionary novel time and what mate
preferences are really sensitive to is
what we reward culturally what we assign
status to so you can assign status about
anything actually that's a bit of advice
i'd give to incels create your own
status game find your little niche
because
i'm never going to be a great mating
success if i go to the nightclub and try
to pull the love island gym bunny right
not going to happen
they want a different type of guy but if
i'm at a debate festival or something
like that and
intellectually stimulating kind of
environment i might blow someone's hair
back you know that's my kind of arena
and so you really have to and there's
any amount of uh status domains now so i
would encourage themselves to kind of
find a smaller niche because proximity
alone uh breeds kind of intimacy as well
you know but
that's another thing that often people
used to meet their partner at work and
that's problematic now suddenly which is
um
it seems
a bit of a kind of a not well thought
out idea to just say suddenly you
shouldn't do that at all i'm thinking of
my
my former colleague she used to really
want to meet someone and she wouldn't go
online she wouldn't go on the online
dating apps and i said where are you
going to meet someone you leave the
office at five you get on the train and
then you're home to sleep and then
you're back in the office again if
you're not going to meet someone at the
office are you going to meet someone on
the train and you won't go on the apps
so it's like she's really
creating a really small world for
herself and it was a
struggle
hey constantin do you love trigonometry
i'm from russia i cannot love anything
apart from vodka miserable literature
and a horrendous downfall of my people
but yes i find trigonometry satisfactory
and do you like live shows of course but
only if it's check of play about
collapse of russian aristocracy as they
face death and obscurity before the
glorious might of the proletariat and
the beautiful revolution
okay mate well if you like trigonometry
live shows then get your credit card out
for the lads because we're coming to the
edinburgh festival this august we have
only booked two shows august 6th and 7th
because if we do more the comedy
industry will treat us like the tsars
and execute us that's right we're going
to be in edinburgh for two days only
saturday's guest is andrew doyle which
is sure to sell out our other guest is
leo curse which means when nicola
sturgeon hears about it she'll ban us
from scotland herself tickets are sure
to sell out and when they're gone
they're gone click on the link below and
we'll see you in edinburgh on the 6th
and 7th of august at the gilded balloon
teviet come and see us before hordes of
left-wing comedians try to put us in
gulag
what advice would you give if you see a
friend or a little brother or maybe your
son start progressing down this path and
you can see spending more and more time
online maybe saying things that starts
ringing alarm bells in your head how do
you help someone like that
uh yeah i think it is uh about kind of a
cultivating a meaning in in young
people's lives beyond just this kind of
online identity um you know get them
more active doing more things hobbies uh
in my previous uh professional
background i worked as a careers advisor
and the we have a kind of a big problem
in schools where young people are just
doing less stuff it's like you know you
in my class if you asked people what
your hobbies were they had all sorts of
different hobbies or they were going
different places or
out and about engaging with the world
and whereas now it's kind of i don't do
anything i'm just gaming or i'm online
i don't want to kind of uh
you know really villainize gaming or
anything like that there's no i'm a
massive gamer right
and it can be kind of but in my time it
kind of i used to be when i had time
yeah right but it used to be kind of
more community based right where you
gather around and you play nintendo 64
against each other now it seems to be a
very locked into a headset
not even talking to someone who could be
far around the other side of the world
it just seems a bit more of an insular
isolated thing yeah and that would
suggest from what you were saying there
that actually
we're going to see the in-cell community
grow because as we become more online
more men are beginning to become
disenfranchised therefore more insults
yeah there's no sign that this wider
mating crisis which affects more than
just in cells it affects the women as
well um investment bankers morgan
stanley released a forecast saying that
by the year 2030 they predict that 44 of
working age women will be single and
childless which is great for them having
the access to a lot of worker drones but
is it clear that single and childless
and i'm libertarian as far as people's
choices go i want people to be able to
be full-time stay-at-home mom work
full-time work part-time whatever you
want but it's not clear that working for
morgan stanley a 60-hour work week is
that liberating compared to starting a
family or you know it's um that seemed
like a they call it the rise of the she
economy and uh it's like they've figured
out the workplace now women are really
killing it in the workplace we have
access to them so
that that's a yeah it's a kind of a
stark prediction but and how much of
this again this is going to be a
controversial question how much of this
is actually
there's a lot there's some women out
there have got unrealistic expectations
we just touched on it about what they're
going to get from a mate you often hear
it with women with women in london i
want a man who's six foot who earns this
amount of money who does this who does
that who's good looking who's funny
who's it and i'm like you've just
described the gay bloke love so you're
never gonna but
yeah
but but on the other side then if you
are a single woman
why wouldn't you want that and if
there's no reason why you should take
anything less why should they settle
they don't need the economic support so
my single female friends they're looking
for love they're looking for a a great
guy and you know my pushback to that
would be you're looking for something
that is completely idealized and doesn't
exist in the real world there is no such
thing as a perfect guy but they might
say that unless they can have their
idealized version of perfect they would
prefer be single and this is actually
across a failure of cross-sex
mind-reading for incels because they
always say well there's no such thing as
a female in cell because
they can always get something they just
need women just need to lower their
standards and they can get access to sex
but i think they're underestimating just
the extent to which women
don't want to have sex with men they
don't want to have sex with right yeah
it's not a net good for them it's
actually a cost inflicting and also
women aren't looking for sex anyway
right or even to settle with a guy you
know to have to lower their standards
they see that as well something is
better than nothing whereas women are
like no no it really isn't um it
actually would inflict a cost on me
because they risk a lot
with sex you know yeah
that's really really interesting
wow this is a 44 single childless women
i mean that is not a recipe for a
healthy society perhaps not yeah
considering
what we know about young male syndrome
and yeah but it's not good for young
women because women want to just to have
a partner and to have kids a lot of them
and the societal impact of that society
just really yeah really because
from if we go even more historically to
our evolutionary history uh 83 of human
societies have been preferentially
poliginous meaning one man and multiple
wives
so the cultures that began to practice
monogamy began to flourish more than
cultures that didn't because the main
cultural advantage of monogamy is the
egalitarian distribution of women and
your viewers are probably going to
really chastise me to talk about
distribution of women but you're
speaking as a scientist right as opposed
to yeah you know yeah don't care if we
talked about the distribution of women
it'd be a different thing but you're
speaking professionally right so tell us
about bird distribution
so if you do have that surplus
population of young men if you
they're out status seeking they're out
competing for mates if you free them up
from that competition they have an
investment in society and their economic
output goes up and they're they're not
killing each other as much they're not
smashing each other's faces and outside
the weather spoons because they've got a
wife and two kids at home right exactly
they've got an investment at stake in
the future
um but it's funny because there's an
anthropologist called helen fisher who
works with match.com on their kind of
relationship scientist stuff she was she
asked um
kind of i can't remember what culture it
was but it was a poligionous culture
she asked the man who had three wives
she was walking along with them she said
how many wives would you want in an
ideal world and he had three and he just
paused
and leaned in close and said
none
because in poliginous marriages the
sister wives fight a lot they poison
each other's children it's no picnic
like so the monogamy cultural norm and
i'm all for freedom and for people to
have individual choice for however they
want to build their life and
relationship structure remain single be
polyamorous whatever it is you want to
do that's my
sensibility on it
but
it is an absolute finding that a strong
cultural norm of monogamy uh has led
cultures to flourish for that very
reason and do you think another part of
the problem as well is that
like you intimated
our society we've become more feminized
we've become more feminized we've become
this only the education system has we
celebrate femininity more we don't do
the same with masculinity we talk about
toxic masculinity so a lot of the time
you go online it does feel like in many
ways quite an anti-masculine space yeah
and something i'd add to that is what i
would call the obligation for success so
we've done a great job of egalitarianism
of
a woman could leave school or a girl
could leave school and say i'm going to
be a stay-at-home mom i'm going to work
part-time or i'm going to work full-time
the man doesn't have that option he
leaves school and knows he has success
success or success or he doesn't
he's not um he's not going to find a
partner really you know so i'd quibble
you with you on the woman's stay-home
mom because a lot of women are demonized
actually for for making that choice
which is again a problem right and you
could see maybe how that might be driven
by the likes of morgan stanley
yeah quite and also as well what about
the geographical element of it because i
would imagine that if you grew up for
instance in a in a town somewhere
outside of london which has got very
little industry poor areas like the
northeast or maybe the south west like
cornwall you're more likely to be an
insole because there's just less
opportunity yeah absolutely and that's
what the
researchers found that they could
predict the geographic areas based on
high income inequality so just that
overall and the lower gender pay gaps
although i'd imagine actually london
would be much more likely to be
somewhere that meets those standards
wouldn't it perhaps higher income
inequality overall perhaps yeah yeah and
what you might see there in london is
more of that status striving seeking
behavior we've got knife crime where uh
forming a gang or getting involved in
gang violence might be actually a
strategy to achieve enough status in
your little arena um if you have no
economic chance you might as well take
your chance on gang violence yeah and
let me ask you this is unrelated but you
brought it up in terms of monogamy
is that
is how natural is that to human beings
right so i actually gave a talk on the
evolution of monogamy uh and the answer
is that we kind of have
evolved psychology for both uh so you
know
infidelity exists in every culture in
the world even in those punishable by
debt so it but we also have pair bonding
psychology there's a lot about our
biology that points to us being uh more
naturally kind of uh monogamous or at
least pair bonding but humans have
always kind of serially mated they they
mate they leave their mate they form
another mateship it's not like
strict monogamy always and without the
cultural norm you tend to maybe veer
more towards polygeny um but like i was
saying we're very sensitive to um
to those cultural cues so if you make
literally that's what happened you had
agriculture came around and you got
stark inequality of mating success so
people were able to for the first time
stockpile resources and get massive
income inequality and they monopolized
the mating opportunities too so
to stop that you had to create the
cultures that created a strong cultural
norm of monogamy that
it's tough to stick to at times um
but if there's a strong cultural norm
people will strive to stick to it and
that leads cultures to flourish so with
that in mind then and the stuff that
we've been talking about today with the
dating apps or the fact that a large
number of men are excluded from that or
certainly feel excluded are we sort of
heading towards a direction where
there's less monogamy and the elite
quote-unquote men at the top are
hoovering up more than one woman at a
time and and playing that field for
longer and
maybe you start to see cultural
movements where you're going well if a
man can afford to blah blah blah then
why shouldn't he have three wives do you
know what i mean yeah that would be i
mean it's radical to kind of think of it
but it's not it seems the direction
we're going in just on the on the found
on the like the foundational data
because some of the data shows that we
the mating pattern is kind of like
effective polygony so one statistic
about that is compared to 2002 men in
2013 had similar uh number of mates
overall but what they showed was the top
20 percent had a a a huge um like
25 increase in the number of mates and
the top five percent of men had a
massive 38 percent increase so it was
really really dramatic this big skew i
think with the economy given that women
can like earn their own money very well
uh it's less likely that they'll say
they need to share a mate they don't
typically like to do that unless they
have to right so it's a
and one of the advantages to polygyny
that they always say is oh well women
have access to a high quality mate and
they can share them but they don't
really like to do that so unless they
have to i think we're more likely to see
a rise of singlehood and kind of this
atomized uh sexual kind of culture where
you have
uh sexual experiences become more
individual and uh less uh long-term
commitment perhaps um
that seems to me like i mean it's not
great for men but for women that is just
awful perhaps and perhaps for children
too because uh completely two parents it
has always but that's that's really not
what women tend to be looking for like
they'll they might pretend that they are
but but generally speaking in the long
run that's not what they're looking for
and if you've got an environment where
that's happening there's going to be a
lot of miserable people sure but the
evolved preference for women to kind of
seek him a male with resources who will
provision her and her offspring with
resources is because for the vast
majority of revolutionary history that
was important if it's no longer the case
if she can get her own work and
provision her child
as well as getting a mate then maybe
it's not as much of a problem but i
think
well you think we're going to get to a
point where
uh a senior executive at goldman sachs
who's female is going to be quite
comfortable dating a guy who just plays
video games all day
i don't see that happening right no
certainly
no
i i would see that she would probably
rather than commit to someone lower
status than herself that she will
concentrate her mating towards those
minority of men she is interested in but
of course they will be commitment
adverse because they're in the minority
right and she will struggle to get them
to commit so there is some evidence so i
always like debate with other
researchers about whether we're in this
mating crisis at all because they point
to some evidence that hypergamy is
actually a little bit in decline so
women are inevitably as they succeed so
well in the workplace are beginning to
mate a mate down so like
marry men who earn less than themselves
or are less educated but even the
researchers in that paper they say we
can't speak to the perceived
difficulties women have felt in
faking this mate and there's also some
really worrying evidence that shows that
uh domestic violence instances are it's
a huge predictor if the man in the
partnership earns this is a new study
out based on 21 000 women across 24 eu
countries
talking about a big predictor of
intimate partner violence is the man
earning less than the woman of all all
different types
so that's when a man feels insecure
about protect that's the risk factor
when he feels like he's potentially
about to lose his mate which
is more likely if he's earning less than
her
so that's a worrying a worrying finding
we also see that this decline in
hypergamy has appeared in lockstep with
an increase in female not male
infidelity so male infidelity has always
been quite quite common and quite
prevalent but that's remained stable
over time
whereas female infidelity has increased
40 in the last 50 years well that makes
sense i mean if your perceived mate
value of your partner is lower then of
course you're going to be more likely to
and if you're in a world where your
peers are these really impressive dudes
in the bank or whatever it might be uh
yeah it's uh and access to do it
anonymously with no reputation damage
yeah it's a but that's that's a stark
finding a 40 increase in 50 years what a
happy world you're painting for us right
we seem we've this has been a brilliant
interview great thank you but one of the
things we don't seem to have spoken
about when it comes to themselves just
bringing it back to them
is the element the biological element
which is testosterone how much do we
know about the in cells and testosterone
levels are these simply people who are
suffering from low testosterone which
would explain a lot of the behaviors it
would explain things like depression etc
that's interesting i was contacted a
couple of weeks ago by a team of
researchers who want to get and study
that and uh actually measure
testosterone levels i think it would be
very interesting um a couple of
conflicting hypotheses on that you in
our study we found that in cells scored
very high on sociosexual desire which
they have a lot of desire so that would
indicate a lot of testosterone and what
drops someone's testosterone is uh
constantine i'm sorry you might not want
to hear this but having a child
as soon as the man has a child is
testosterone
[Laughter]
when they have a child the evolution
wants them to concentrate on
staying at home not out gallivanting
right so the tea drops down a bit um so
that's one hypothesis that in cells
might have higher testosterone but you
would predict that they'd be out seeking
mates yeah um more with that and another
hypothesis is that they're they're not
seeking mates because they're low on t
and um
interesting to find out one way or the
other but your levels are also affected
by behavior as well like having a mate
having success with mates that would
raise your testosterone levels wouldn't
it and also watching pornography
lowers your testosterone i'm not sure
about uh watching pornography lower
testosterone um but it might interfere
with amazing mechanisms like
like why we spoke about the counterfeit
fitness cues yeah
because the message is you're achieving
mating success so it wouldn't stand to
reason that it would lower testosterone
uh inherently i appreciate we're talking
to a scientist so our standards for
evidence is different your standard is
is there a research paper our standard
is oh i remember reading somewhere that
yeah okay and i do remember reading
somewhere that just that i'm sorry to
make it explicit but it's masturbating
to pornography lowers your testosterone
right do you remember seeing that okay
could be wrong fact check me i do think
that a lot of kind of porn research is
very ideologically by religious groups
uh so
tread very carefully i would say um i
can put you in touch with a couple of
porn researchers i would trust on it uh
i'm certainly not an expert on it yeah
william it's been an absolutely
brilliant interview thank you so much
for coming on the show uh the final
question we always ask is what's the one
thing we're not talking about but we
really should be well i think we began
to talk about it a little bit today uh
that kind of wider mating crisis but
something totally different if i could
just give two two examples uh free
speech because i think people really pay
lip service uh to free speech and don't
really stand by it as a value so fair
play to you and the program i know
that's a fundamental value
of your kind of mission statement and i
certainly felt like i could speak freely
in the interview so that was great
thanks thank you so much it's been an
absolute pleasure we're going to ask you
a couple of questions from our local
supporters that only they get to see in
a second but before we let you go uh
where's the best place to follow your
work uh how should people keep up with
your research and so on so uh like a lot
of academics i spend far too much time
on twitter so my handle is at costello
william so my name just inversed and
you'll find i'll post about all our
latest research and studies and things
like that
all the time fantastic william thank you
so much make sure to go and follow him
and thank you for watching and listening
we will see you very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one
or raw show all of them go out at 7 p.m
uk time and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
is in salford
not simply a form of narcissism
[Music]